c'est ici sur cette portion du doubs à
dole qu'un jeune homme de 25 ans s'est
noyé ce vendredi soir cette zone
paisible à première vue est
particulièrement dangereuse à cause de
son courant et ses remous et pourtant
deux jours après ce drame elle a
toujours la cote auprès des baigneurs
ça nous a tous un peu choqués bien n'a
eu l'an dernier je crois aussi
mais après nous ça ça nous allait rester
pas plus que ça nous on a aucun danger
enfin il n'y a pas de on a toujours
sauter ici pour éviter à tout prix un
nouvel accident la police municipale
joue la carte de la prévention et incite
les baigneurs à aller dans des zones
surveillées à dole
une seule solution le parc aquatique de
la ville
mathieu ogier y est maître nageur et
connaît parfaitement les risques de la
rivière s'ils ont pensé qu'il ya déjà
des courants qui se mélange il ya une
partie rien il ya l'autre descend au
niveau d'un barrage et il ya certains
trous avec des tourbillons
voilà le problème c'est que les gens ça
n'ont pas forcément conscience et il
peut y avoir
voilà des dangers lorsqu'on a on a du
mal à nager la mairie de dole a interdit
la baignade dans le doubs par un arrêté
municipal rarement respectées par des
baigneurs qui n'en n'ont souvent même
pas connaissance
j'ai pas vu de panneaux et c'est ça qui
m'avait étonné parce que les gens
continuent à venir c'est comme dans
beaucoup d'endroits en fait un chacun
prend sa part de responsabilité on sait
ce qui s'est passé moi je ne vais pas
nager la bâche une nageuse mais je n'y
vais pas en fin de semaine prochaine le
maire de dole et le sous préfet vont se
rencontrer pour discuter des mesures à
appliquer pour sécuriser les cours d'eau
de la ville qui ont déjà connu quatre
morts en deux ans